today marks a new chapter in our fight
against this virus
ever since the pandemic hit our shores
almost a year ago we have known that a
vaccine would be
critical to set us free
so all through this arduous year and it
has been an arduous year
while we've been working night and day
to fight the virus and
keep it under control we've been
striving to to develop the vaccines that
can give us hope
and let us eventually release the curbs
on our freedoms that have bound us for
so long
thanks to the incredible work of the
vaccines task force
the business secretary and kate bingham
we've already amassed a huge portfolio
of different
vaccine candidates we've backed seven
vaccines
and ordered 357 million doses on behalf
of the whole uk
one of the biggest portfolios per capita
in the world
we've said from the start that a vaccine
must be safe and
effective before we'd even consider
deploying it
any vaccine must go through a rigorous
process of clinical trials involving
thousands of people and extensive
independent scrutiny from the mhra
one of the world's most respected
medical regulators
today i'm delighted to inform the house
that the mhra has issued the clinical
authorization
of the pfizer biontech vaccine this is
a monumental step forward
it's no longer if there's going to be a
vaccine it's when
in our battle against the virus help is
on its way
today is a triumph for all those who
believe in science
a triumph for ingenuity a triumph for
humanity and i want to thank everyone
who's played their part in this
achievement
the team at pfizer the team of
scientists at beyond tech
the volunteers who stepped up and took
part in clinical trials
and to the mhra themselves who've made
sure
that this is a vaccine that we can all
have faith in
thanks to their efforts i can confirm
that the uk is the first
country in the world to have a
clinically
approved coronavirus vaccine for supply
and now our task is to make use of the
fruits of this scientific endeavor to
save
lives mr speaker we've spent months
preparing for this day
so that as soon as we got the green
light we would be ready to go
we were the first country in the world
to pre-order supplies of this
successful vaccine and we have 40
million doses pre-ordered for delivery
over the coming months
enough for 20 million people because two
jabs are required for each
following authorization the next stage
is to
test each batch of the vaccine for
safety
and i can confirm that batch testing has
been completed this morning
for the first deployment of eight
hundred thousand doses of the vaccine
these doses are for the whole united
kingdom
this morning i chaired a meeting of
health ministers from the devolved
administrations to ensure
the rollout is coordinated nationwide
this will be one of the biggest civilian
logistical efforts that we've faced as a
nation
it will be difficult there will be
challenges and complications
but i know that the nhs is equal to the
task
rolling out the vaccine free at the
point of delivery
according to clinical need not ability
to pay
is in the finest tradition of our
national health service
and i'm delighted to confirm that the
nhs will be able to start vaccinating
from
early next week the whole purpose of the
vaccine
is to protect people from covid so we
can get lives back to normal
so we will prioritize the groups who are
at greatest risk
this morning the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization has
published its advice
setting out the order of priority
according to that clinical need
and this includes the care home
residents and their carers
the over 80s the frontline health and
social care workers
and we will deliver according to
clinical prioritization
and operational necessity because of the
need to hold the vaccine
at minus 70 to make it makes this
vaccine
particularly challenging to deploy and
while we begin
vaccination next week the bulk of the
vaccinations will be in the new year but
i would urge anyone
called forward for vaccination by the
nhs to respond quickly
to protect themselves their loved ones
and their community
mr speaker over the next few months we
will see vaccines delivered in three
different ways
first we will begin vaccinations in
hospital hubs second will deploy through
local community services including gps
and in due course pharmacies too
and third we'll stand up vaccination
centers in conference centers and sports
venues for example
to vaccinate large numbers of people as
more vaccines come on stream
this is an important step but we are not
there yet and so i want to stress
that we must all keep playing our part
keep following the new rules that the
house approved overwhelmingly yesterday
and remember the basics like hands face
space
and get a test that we know from
experience are so
important in keeping the virus under
control
before i finish mr speaker may i also
update the house on another bit of good
news
from today i'm absolutely thrilled to
say that we can
safely allow visits in care homes for
those who test negative for covid19
coronavirus has denied so many people
the simple pleasure of seeing a loved
one which is so
precious to so many especially in our
care homes
this is only possible because of the
success we've had
in building one of the biggest testing
capacities in europe
and working with local and national
teams
working together side by side something
we've often discussed
right across this house we've worked
hard on testing
we've worked hard on the vaccine our
strategy of suppressing the virus until
a vaccine can make us safe
that strategy is working and i'm
delighted
that we'll be able to see families and
friends come together
ahead of christmas thanks to this
improvement
mr speaker this is a day to remember
frankly in a year to forget we can see
the way out of this but we're not there
yet
so let's keep our resolve keep doing our
bit to keep people safe
until science can make us free